خلينا نروح من عمان ل امريكا او كانت احلى
من عمان الى ريتا سليمان
مذيعه في قناه الحدث كانت وباتت مراسلتنا
في واشنطن ولاول مره تعيش شريت اختبار انا
امريكيا فريدا وهو الاحتفال بعيد الشكر
طبعا الاساس في الاحتفال هو طبق الديك
الرومي وقد قررت زميلتنا العزيزه ريتا ان
تنقل لنا التجربه الثقافيه والاقتصاديه في
نفس الوقت لان اميركا بيقول بساطه تعيش
فتره ميناء تضخم تحيه يا ريت
[موسيقى]
انها المره الاولى لي ولي عائلتي في
الولايات المتحده التي نحتفل فيها بالعيد
الاهم لديهم عيد الشكر من المستحيل ان
تندمج بالمجتمع الامريكيه ان لم تحضر
ديكان روميا على طاوله غذاء العيد
دعونا نبداها سويا
[موسيقى]
هذا هو المكون الاهم
الامريكيون يشتركون حقيقه من ارتفاع اسعار
كل ما هو متعلق بعيد الشكر من ارتفاع سعر
الوقود لانهم سيسافرون للقاء عائلاتهم الى
اسعار السلع والمكونات التي سيشترونها
[موسيقى]
اطباق تقليديه معينه علينا تحضرها في هذا
العيد الديك الرومي بالطبع بالاضافه الى
الجزر سلطه الذره التفاح
والكرامبري او ما يعرف بالكرز لدينا
[موسيقى]
امريكيا كل شيء اصبح جاهز ولكن لابد ان
نضيفه عنصرا عربيا يسمحوا لنا الامريكان
الحلوى عربيه
[موسيقى]
شكرا دي مشاركتي وعائلتي اول تجربه عيد
شكر في الولايات المتحده
[موسيقى]
تحيه كبيره